The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AUDE OLIVA: Thank you very
much for the introduction.
Good morning, everyone.
So I'm very pleased to be here.
It's the first time I visit.
So I would like to give you
a tour during this lecture
about how you can predict
human visual memory,
and actually an
interdisciplinary account
of the methods you can
use together in order
to have basically a view of what
people can remember or forget.
So the specific question
we are going to ask today
is, well, we are experiencing
and seeing all the time
a lot of digital information.
First you see in the
real world, but also you
are exposed to many,
many videos and images.
So vision and visual memory
is one of the core concept
of cognition.
And the question
we ask is, can we
predict which image or graph
or face or words or videos
or piece of
information or event is
going to be memorable
or forgettable
for a group of people,
and eventually for a given
individual?
So let's take a
moment to imagine
that we will be able
to predict accurately
the memory of people.
Well, this will be very
useful to understand
the mechanism of
human memory, both at
the cognitive and neuroscience
level, system level,
as well as possibly
diagnose memory problem,
short-term visual memory,
long-term visual memory, that
may arise possibly in an acute
way or developing over time,
as well as design
mnemonic aids in order
to recall better informations.
But beside basic science, if
you could predict information
that are memorable
or forgettable,
there is a realm of
application that you
could work on or basically
propose that lie really
everywhere between the data
visualization or the slogan,
make basically slogan
better, as well
as all the realm of education,
the individual differences that
may arise between people.
Someone will not
learn very well.
Well, what can we do
in order to increase
the memory of visual information
that this person can grasp?
As well as various
applications--
social networking, faces,
retrieve better images,
and so on.
So understanding what
make an information
memorable or
forgettable basically
is really a very
inter-disciplinary question,
something very exciting
for us to work on,
because there's a
lot, a lot of future
in working in that topic.
So this is a topic we started
in my lab a few years ago.
And the best for you
to get a sense of how
you start working, for
instance, on memory
is to do the kind of
game and the experiment
we had people doing.
So welcome to the
Visual Memory Game.
A stream of images will
be presented on the screen
for one second each.
And your task is to--
If you are in front of your
computer you will press a key.
But what you're going to
do is play the game with me
and clap your hand
anytime you see
any image that you saw before.
So you're going to have to
be attentive, because images,
they go by fast in this
rapid stream of images.
And so you will be
getting feedback.
So it's a very straightforward
memory experiment.
And this is the
first step in order
to get some score on a
lot of images regarding
the type of information
that people will naturally
forget or naturally remember.
So let's do the game.
So are you ready?
All right.
So clap your hand
whenever you see a repeat.
So this is what will rerun.
Very simple images.
[CLAPPING]
Fine.
Excellent.
So images are shown one second.
There's a one-second interval.
[CLAPPING]
You're good.
No false alarm.
Excellent.
All right.
So that was one of the level,
level 9, out of 30 complete.
And so here's the
game that people had.
They could play this game for
five minutes, had a break,
and come back.
And this game had a lot
of success, and we run it.
I'm going to show many
results about this.
So you could see your score, the
amount of money you have done.
This was run on Amazon
Mechanical Turk.
And this allow us to collect
all around the world a lot
of data regarding
many, many images.
So those visual
memory experiment
were set up by Phillip
Isola from MIT.
And you can basically
play that game
for any kind of information
displayed visually.
So we did it for pictures,
faces, and words.
And you're going
to see the result.
So let's start
with the pictures.
In the first experiment,
we presented 10,000 images,
and about 2,200 we
repeated many, many time.
So those were the one where
we collected the score.
So for a given
subject, those images
were actually seen only once.
Twice, sorry.
So you have the stream
of images at the top.
So, for instance, an image
will be shown after 90, 100,
110 images or so.
And if this image was one
that the subject recognized,
then he will press a key.
So it's exactly the
design you just did.
And when first you look
at the type of images
that are highly memorable
or forgettable, well,
there's a trend
that we all expect,
is images who are kind of
either funny or have something
distinctive or
something different,
or if people are
doing various action,
or of some object that are
kind of out of context,
those tend to be memorable.
And, in general,
landscape or images
that don't have any activity
tend to be forgettable.
So we have those that score
for more than 2,000 images
from that experiment.
So one of the first
thing we need to know
is, well, everyone
is playing that game,
and we can have their
own memory score.
But in order to know if
some images are indeed
memorable for all of us or a
good amount of the population,
we need to see if there is
consistency between people.
So here is a simple
measure we do.
You have a group of people
looking at those images,
and we have the memory score.
And you can split
the group into two,
and rank according to the
average of the first group,
the images, from
the most memorable
to the less memorable.
And then you can also
rank the same images
in the second group.
And if the two group were
identical to each other,
you will get a correlation
between those two ranking of 1.
And what we observe when we
split repetitively the group
into two like this is
we observe a correlation
of 0.75, which is pretty high.
And this give us basically
the maximum performances
that we can expect when
we have a group of people
that can predict
the rank of images
of another group of people.
And actually, here
is the curve that
shows what the 0.75
consistency look like.
So on the x-axis, you
have the image rank
according to the
group number one,
so the images with the
highest memory score.
So I have a group of
them that are above 90.
And it's normal.
The group number one in
blue decrease as images
are less and less memorable.
So that's like basically
your ground truth curve.
And the green show
the group number
two, totally independent people,
and also the performances
that they got for each
bins along the image rank.
And you can see the curve
are pretty close by.
So a correlation of
0.75 look like this.
So it means that, with
independent group of people,
there are some images that
are going to be systematically
more memorable or forgettable.
You can see the full range going
below 40% for the images that
were forgotten, up to
95 for the one that
were systematically remembered.
But, importantly,
a group of person
is going to predict
another group of person.
So there's several
ways to test memory.
The way we tested memory
here to get ground truth
was an objective measurement.
You see an image again,
and if you remember it,
you press a key.
So that's an
objective measurement.
But you can also
ask people, do you
think you will
remember an image?
Do you think someone else
will remember an image?
We also run those
subjective memory score.
And we observed this
very interesting trend
that the subjective
judgment do not
predict image memorability,
which means that,
if you ask yourself, am
I going to remember this?
Well, basically,
maybe, maybe not.
So subjective judgment of what
you think your memory will be
or what you think the memory
of someone else will be
is not correlated with the true
memory, with whatever you're
going to remember or not.
So this was very
interesting, because it
shows that objective measurement
should be needed here in order
to really get a sense of what
people will remember or forget.
We basically have many papers
on this topic since 2010.
They are all on the web site.
And then some of them will look
at the correlation existing
between memory, so
the fact that you're
going to remember
certain kind of images,
and other attributes,
for instance, aesthetic.
And, again, we found
that memorability is
distinct from image aesthetic.
This means that
basically you could
have an image that is
judged very beautiful,
or, on the contrary,
ugly or boring.
And in those cases,
you will still
remember those two images.
So we found this absence of a
correlation between those two
attribute in our values studies.
We replicate this with other
data set and faces as well.
So it looks like what
you will remember
is this notion of
distinctiveness,
but it can be beautiful or ugly.
It doesn't matter.
You can still either
remember it or forget it.
So you had this question
about the notion of the lag.
So the lag is in that you
could test visual memory
after a few seconds or a
few intervening images,
or you could test it
a few minutes or even
one hour later, or
even days later.
So because we were
running those experiments
on Amazon Mechanical Turk,
we did not do the dates.
However, we did run
some with a larger gap,
up to 1,000 different
images between the first
and the second repeat.
And so here is the
design, the one
that I show you for the
about 100 images intervening
between the first and
the second repeat.
But what about a shorter
and a longer time scale?
So all that work
is also published.
You can go and download the
paper and see the details.
But the basic idea is that
the ranks were conserved.
So if one image
is very memorable,
one of the top after,
let's say, a few seconds,
will still be
memorable after hours.
And if an image is forgettable
or one of the most forgettable
after a few seconds, will still
be forgettable after hours.
So the fact that the magnitude,
the percentage of images
remembered decrease is normal.
That is known from memory
research for decades.
So it is expected.
However, memorability
here is basically
the rank, which is an image, is
for a population independently
basically of the
row, the magnitude.
One of the most memorable given
this condition is forgettable.
And we did those
experiment, both on the web
as well as in the lab,
because in the lab we
could control for more factors.
And it was very interesting
to see in the lab experiment
that only after 20 second there
were images that were totally
forgotten by a good group,
a good amount of people.
So some image seems to really--
basically do not
stick and be gone in I
don't know how many second.
We did not go really
to short-term memory.
We work starting in long-term
memory at 20 seconds and so on.
But there's this phenomenon.
So it suggests that
there are some features
into the visual information
that are encoded
in less details than others or
with more details than others.
And what's very
interesting is then
you can go to
neuroscience and basically
start studying the
level of details
or the quality of
encoding of an image
and see where in
the visual pathway
an image basically is gone
after 20 seconds or something
like this.
So important point--
the rank is conserved.
So we also look at those
principle of memorability
that we found for
images in faces.
So faces is a very
interesting material
to work with, because
basically it's
all images that look alike.
So you have basically
one object and look
at many, many exemplars.
And there's no reason to believe
that this high consistency we
will find for
images as different
as amphitheater and the parking
and so on, and landscape,
this high consistency
will be found with faces.
So we gather a data
set of 10,000 faces.
The paper is published,
as well as the entire data
set is available on the web.
So you can go and download
those 10,000 faces as well as
all the attribute
that we found where
we study with the data set.
And we also found
the same phenomenon,
very high consistency, both in
the correct positive responses,
when people remember
seeing a face,
as well as in the false alarm,
when people did not see a face
but falsely thought
that they saw a face
and basically pressed the key.
So this very high consistency
for both measurement
suggests that, again, in the
facial features of people,
or at least the way
a photo is taken,
there is something at the
level of the image that
will make a face highly
memorable or highly forgettable
for most people.
So all the details of this
study are actually on the web.
It was a pretty complex study
to run, because while we have
very different
sensitivity to faces,
so the race effect on
basically where we grew up,
so we know there's a lot
of individual differences.
So the way this study
was run is the collection
of faces we have followed
the US census in terms
of male, female, race, and age.
We started at 18
years old and older.
So did our population as well.
So on the group, we
show a collection
of faces that did match the
population, the people who
were running the study.
And, as I say, all the data
are available on the web
if some of you want to go back
and do additional analysis.
So we kept going with this.
So we have the consistency
in the visual material.
So now what about words?
So words is a very
interesting case,
because now you
do know the words.
But are there some kind of
words that we can predict
are more forgettable
or memorable?
Again, there's no reason to
believe a high consistency will
be found.
But we've run the study
twice with two different data
set, again, ten thousand item,
and two different set of words.
And we found, again, very
high consistency, which
is that a collection of
words were systematically
remembered by people and
others were forgettable.
So this work that is
done in collaboration
with Mahowald, Isola,
Gibson, and Fedorenko
is under submission.
But let me give you a taste
of the words that we found.
So what make words more
memorable or forgettable?
So here is a cartoon that give
you the basic idea is, well,
if there is one word
for one meaning,
so basically a word
has a single meaning,
it will have a tendency
to be much more
memorable than if a
words has many meanings.
So in the paper, we also
look at the correlation
between memorability and image
ability or frequency and so on.
And all this is describe,
but really the main factor
is this one-to-one referent
between a word and its meaning
or concept.
So let's look at
some of the example.
The paper will come with the
two data set and thousand
of words that were found
memorable and forgettable.
So I think if you
write a letter,
you should not say that
your student is excellent
but that she is fabulous.
And our research is not a blast.
It's in vogue.
And the idea of a team is not
irrational, they are grotesque.
So those are just a few
example of the words
that on average,
of the three first,
had more referent
and the tendency
to be more forgettable
because they
might be used for many
more things than the one.
I also notice a lot
of the French words
tend to be memorable.
So we do find this
stable principle
that you can
predict the content,
can predict what type
of images, faces,
words that are memorable.
And we also did it
for visualization,
starting working on
the topic of education.
So this is very useful,
because at least
at the level of a group, you can
start making that prediction.
Oh, I also have
massive and avalanche.
Forgot about it.
So now that we were able
to have all those data
and see that there
is this consistency,
then one of the next question
you can look at is, OK, well,
if it seems that we
all have a tendency
to remember the same image,
can we find a neural signature
into the human brain?
So the question of memorability,
is it a perceptual or memory
question?
Because in all our
experiment, the images
are shown for a short time.
And then, when
they are repeated,
you see them a second time.
But basically, all the action
is at the perception level.
Whenever you perceive this
image for half a second or one
second, there is
something going on here
at the perception
level that is going
to bias if this image is going
to basically go into memory
or not.
So, knowing this,
if we want to look
at the potential neural
framework of memorability,
we have to look at
the entire brain.
We have to look at
all the region that
have been found to be
related to perception,
faces perception, picture
perception, object, space,
and so on, as well as the
medial temporal lobe region,
more in the middle
of the brain, that
have been related to memory.
So this is what we did
with Wilma Bainbridge.
This is her PhD,
basically having
a look at all those region.
And here is the very
simple experiment we run.
So we took a collection
of faces and scene
from the thousands we
have, and where every one,
we'll basically separate
those two between looking
at the region that
are more activated
for seeing versus the region
more activated for faces.
We split it that way,
between the memorable
and the forgettable set.
So in those set,
every images is novel.
So exactly like in
the memory experiment,
we could show them one
time for half a second.
So you had the perception level.
You're in a
perception experiment.
You saw those image one after
the other only one time.
All those images are novel.
So we're going to
look at the contrast
from novel image minus novel
image, from scene minus scene,
from faces minus faces,
except that some images are
highly memorable and some
are highly forgettable.
So other factor that
you have to look at
is, it's still possible that
within those group of images
and faces that are highly
memorable or forgettable,
that there's a lot
of image features
that basically
correlate with those.
So if you take a collection of
images like I shown you before,
and did the environment or
the photo that have people
or action tend to be
memorable versus a landscape
tend to be forgettable?
So here you have a
lot of visual features
that will co-vary with the
dimension of memorability.
So in that study for the
brain, we equalize for that,
because we had enough images.
So here you have a
sample of the two groups
and sample of images and the
type of statistic we look at.
And the two, for
instance, for this scene
were equalized in term of the
type of category you had--
outdoor, indoor, beach,
landscape, house, kitchen,
and so on--
as well as a collection
of low-level features.
And you can see some of
the average signature that
are actually identical on a lot
of low to mid to higher level
image features that were
equalized between the two
group.
So whatever we find
is not going to be
due to simple statistic due to
the image or the type of object
those have.
We could play the same game
for the faces, so we did.
Here are the numbers again,
memorable and forgettable
faces that were also equalized
for various attribute
like attractiveness,
emotion, kindness, happiness,
and so on, as well
as male, female,
race, as well as
expression, and so on.
And you can see that the
statistic, the average faces
for both the memorable
and the forgettable group,
are actually also identical.
So with those group, what's left
is hopefully only the factor
of something else in the image
at the level of a higher image
statistic, because only image
statistic will explain the fact
that very different people
will remember the same faces
and forget the same faces.
But certainly not some of
obvious low-level image
statistic.
Those cannot explain any result.
So two years and
four study later,
we replicated basically
this study four times
with many different matter.
Then, I'm just going
to show you here one
snapshot of the result.
So this is a Multi-variate
Pattern Analysis
looking at the memorable
versus the forgettable groups,
searchlight analysis,
MVPA looking
for the region of the
brain that are more active.
Well, that have a
different pattern.
They are also more active,
but at a different pattern
for memorable faces.
And we find signature
in the hippocampus,
the parahippocampal
area, as well as
the perirhinal that are typical
for memorable faces and scene,
and a new signature in the
visual area or even the higher
visual area, because we
did equalize for those.
So it seems to show that
those MTL region play
a role in a kind of higher-order
statistical perception,
a notion of distinctiveness
that is within those image.
So this suggest that at the
perception of a new image,
could be a face or a scene
or a collection of object
and so on, well, there's already
a signature of this that's
going to guide or bias if this
is going to be put into memory
or not.
And we have those at
the level of the group,
looking now at the
level of individuals.
All right.
So, well, it looks
like we're going,
given your question
is now trying to model
this notion of memorability.
So we have a good case that
there is some information
into the image of a
higher-level status--
we don't know which one--
that cannot be explained by
simple features that make all
of us reacting the same way.
Even our brain do
react the same way.
We also have images, signature
of memorability coming up.
So we have this intrinsic
information that make all of us
remember or forget the same
kind of visual information.
So can we now in a way
imitate or model those result
into an artificial system?
All right.
So you have all heard about the
revolution in computer vision
a couple of years
ago and deep learning
and those neural
networks that are now
able to outperform a lot of--
that were able to
recognize and perform
a lot of task, some of them
at the level of humans,
so recognizing various
object and so on.
And one of the aspect of
those neural networks,
and I'm going to
talk about them,
is that they require
a lot of information.
So you need to teach
them the classes
you want to distinguish.
And they can and need
a lot, a lot of data.
So everything we did so
far, we are getting that
on a couple of thousand images.
And that's really not enough
to even start scratching
computational modeling.
So with Aditya Khosla,
we run recently
a new large-scale
visual memorability
study on Amazon Mechanical
Turk, but this time getting
score for 60,000 photograph.
And you have a set of
a sample over here.
60,000.
They are all going to be
available in a few weeks.
The paper is under revision.
It's looking good.
So as soon as we
have a citation,
we are going to give away all
the data as well as the score
and the images and so on.
And in this
experiment, images were
presented for 600
milliseconds or shorter time,
but they really did
not change much.
So as a snapshot, because
the 60,000 images really
cover a lot of type of photo--
faces, event, action, and
even a graph and so on--
well, you either hear
some that were highly
memorable or forgettable.
There's also the website.
It's not populated
yet with many things,
but it will be very shortly.
And the correlation we
got on that data set
was pretty high again, 0.68.
That was expected.
And the paper explain
the various split we did.
But, again, we find this
very high correlation.
So we do know that there's
something to model there.
And other-- again, a
very quick summary.
The type of images that seems
to be the most memorable
are the one which have a
focus and close settings, that
show some dynamics and
something distinctive, unusual,
a little different, whereas
the less memorable one seems
to have no single focus,
distant view, static,
and more commonalities.
All photos, you can still
find two images that
will be focus and
dynamics, and one of them
will be more memorable
than the other
because it will have something
unusual that now our system can
capture.
So we have this new data set.
We have all the memory score.
We have the high consistency.
How do we even start thinking
about the computational model
of visual memory
or memorability?
Well, in order to give
you a sense of one
of the basic we needs,
in order to even start
thinking of a model, I'm going
to show and run another demo.
So in this demo, you're also
going to see some images.
And clap your hand whenever
you see an image that repeat.
OK?
Exactly the same
game than before.
Ready?
All right.
If everyone play the
game, it will be fun.
OK.
[CLAPPING]
A little false alarm.
False alarm.
[CLAPPING]
Good.
More energy.
[CLAPPING]
Good.
Sorry.
[CLAPPING]
No
[LAUGHTER]
[CLAPPING]
No.
Yes.
[CLAPPING]
No.
AUDIENCE: Too close.
[CLAPPING]
AUDE OLIVA: No.
Yeah, that was-- yes.
[CLAPPING]
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
So for the sake of
the demo, I put here
really images that
are very different,
some you are familiar with.
You have a concept.
You know what it is.
This is a restaurant.
This is an alley.
This is a stadium, and so on.
And some for which either you
don't have a specific concept,
or you have the same concept--
texture, paintings,
texture, texture, texture.
And the basic idea
of memory is you
need to recognize, to put a
unique tag or collection of tag
in order to remember
that individual image.
So the fact that you saw
a collection of texture
or paintings or whatever
you want to call them,
you'll remember that as a group.
But to go to the
individual memory of one,
you're going to need to
have a specific concept.
And in order to
remember it, this
is going to be an abstraction,
a format, a collection of words,
or a coding that make it unique.
So you need to
recognize to remember,
which means that if you
want a model of memory which
start from the raw image--
I'm not in toy world here.
I really start from the
raw image, like the retina.
Well, you're going to need
to build a visual recognition
system first.
So first you need a model
that recognize object
and scene and event and so on.
And then, from this,
there can be a base
to start modeling memory.
So, fortunately, the
field of computer vision
made a lot of progress in
the past couple of years.
So now we do have visual
recognition system
that works pretty well.
I'm going to describe them.
We need to first a visual
recognition system.
All right.
So, what does a visual
recognition system needs to do?
So, well, it's your
Sunday morning.
You're going to the
picnic area, and you're
faced with that view.
You take a photo.
This photo actually
became viral on the web.
And here is the state of the
art of computer vision system.
When it comes to
recognize the object--
I know it's a
different view, but it
works very well for any view--
object recognition
for about 1,000
object category is reaching
human performances so far.
And so this will tell
you this is a black bear,
there's a bench, a table,
and so on, and trees
in the background.
But it's missing the point,
that this is a picnic area.
So you do need at least
two kind of information
in order to reach visual
scene understanding.
You need the scene
and the context,
you need to know the place, and
you need to know the object.
So, as I said, so
far on the challenge
that's called the ImageNet
Challenge in computer vision,
computer vision model average
human performances, which
is 95% correct on exemplars
of objects that have never
been trained on, a new one,
for 1,000 object category.
And recently, we basically
published a few papers
for the other part of visual
scene understanding, the place
and the context.
And this is an
output of our system.
And you can go on the web--
I'm going to give you the
address-- and play with it
and see the performances
of recognizing
the context and the place.
So just to put into context what
the field of computer vision
have been doing for
the past 15 years
is, well, the
number of data set,
the number of images by data
set has been increasing,
so that there's more
exemplar to learn from.
And, in perspective, you can
see that two-years-old kids.
Of course, it will depend on
the sampling you use in order
to have an estimate of the
number of visual information
that the retina sees.
But it sees much,
much more variety
and numbers of visual input.
But right now, both ImageNet,
that is, a data set of objects,
and Places, which is
a data set of scene
I'm going to present to you
now, have about 10 million label
images of many categories.
So label means that for the
places, it will tell you,
this is a kitchen or this
is a conference room, and so
on for hundred of categories.
So 10 million is
largely enough to start
building very serious
visual recognition system,
but it's no near
the human brain.
However, we might
be getting there.
So how do we even start
to build a visual scene
recognition data set?
This is a work we did
and published in 2010,
the Scene Understanding,
or SUN data
set, where we collected the
words from the dictionary that
correspond to places at
the subordinate level--
I'm going to give you example--
and then retrieve a lot
of images from the web.
And there was a total of
900 different categories,
and about 400 of them
have enough exemplars
to build a artificial system.
So instead of going and only
looking to build images,
like to build a data set of
a bedroom and kitchen and so
on, what's happening for
the human brain is that you
have a different environment.
You see there's many
attribute you can put in.
And you are forthcoming
and storytelling and so on.
So most of the places,
it's not only that this is,
for instance, a bedroom,
is that you will go more
to a student bedroom or--
Well, I think those
are student bedroom two
doors from my colleague.
So there are many
type of adjective
that we can use in order
to retrieve images that
will give us a larger panorama
of the type of concept
that are used by the
human brain in order
to recognize environment.
So a simple bedroom.
The tag were put automatically.
Superior bedroom.
Senior bedroom.
Colorful bedroom.
Hotel bedroom.
And so on and so on.
So that was the
retrieval we did,
which means that now,
for every category there
is also a tag in term of
the subtype of environment
this can be.
Messy bedroom.
And a couple of years later,
80 million images later,
and a lot of Amazon
Mechanical Turk experiment,
we are launching this
week the Places2 data set,
with 460 categories, different
categories of environment,
and 10 million images label.
So this is a larger data
set of label images,
with a label to be used right
away for artificial system
learning, deep
learning, and so on.
So here is just a snapshot
of the differences
of the places in term of the
number of exemplars with other
a large data set.
So the Places data
set is actually
part of the ImageNet
challenge this year,
which means that you
can go to ImageNet
and register for the challenge
and download right now,
tonight, eight million
images of places
to use for the learning
of your neural networks,
as well as of a set that
will be used for the testing,
and participate
to the challenge.
So this was launch last
week, and the website
associated with Places
will be launched this week.
And we decided to just give this
away to everyone right away.
We are finishing
up the paper now.
It will be an archive paper.
No time to wait for
month and month.
This is a data set that can
be used by a lot of people
to make progress fast.
And so that's what we are doing.
So, as I said, the
computer vision model
now require, if you use deep
learning, a lot of data.
And we hope that
with this data set,
fast progress are
going to be made.
So what we specifically did is
using the AlexNet deep learning
architecture--
If you don't know
what this is, I
can tell you later how
to basically access
to it with the paper on so on.
This is not my model.
This is a model put
together by Geoffrey Hinton
and collaborator
a few years ago.
And you can download the
model or download the code
and re-train.
So neural net now
basically are based
on the collection
of operation that
are call layers, convolution,
normalization, simple image
processing operation that
you do in a sequence.
You do it one time, then a
second and third and so on.
And then you have those
multi-layers models.
And the number of layers is
still a question of research.
How does layer
correspond to the brain?
I'm going to say a
little bit about that.
And using this simple--
well, this AlexNet model,
we built a scene recognition
system.
And now you can go to
places.csail.mit.edu
with a smartphone will
work, will take a photo.
And it should tell you
the type of environment
the photo represent.
It will give you
several possibilities,
because basically
environment are ambiguous.
They can be of different type.
So I don't know if you can read.
Let me read a few.
The first one, it says,
restaurant, coffee shop,
cafeteria, food court,
restaurant patio.
I guess they all fit.
The second one, parking
lot and driveway.
The third one, conference room,
dining room, banquet hall,
classroom.
That was a difficult one.
And the fourth environment
is patio, restaurant patio,
or restaurant.
So if you go there, you
can also give feedback
if one of the label
match the environment
that you're looking at.
And it should be
above 80% correct.
And this model use 1.5 million
images and 200 categories.
So soon with a great--
we hope that things will be even
more interesting and accurate.
And I took this morning a
couple of photo at breakfast.
So you may all recognize
the scenery here.
So from the breakfast
area looking outside,
it's an outdoor harbor,
dock, boat deck.
Yeah, it could be
actually on a boat
deck looking at the harbor.
And otherwise,
the breakfast area
was restaurant, cafeteria,
coffee shop, food court,
or bar.
All those, again, fits.
So those model now
works very, very well.
So why?
Well, let me tell you why.
So those neural networks,
you can go to any layers
and open them and look at what
every single artificial neuron
do.
So what we call
the receptive field
of every single
unit in the layer
one, the layer two, the
layer three, and so on.
So the first the layer--
here, four layers are shown--
basically learn simple features,
contours and simple texture.
That's called pool1.
And those looks like the type of
responses of the visual cells,
and possibly V1, V2.
I'm going to tell
more about this.
And as you go higher
up in the layers,
then you start having some
texture, some patches,
that make more sense.
And higher up in the layers,
like layer number five,
then you start having
artificial receptive field that
are specific to part of
object, part of scene,
or an entire object by itself.
Like we can see here some
kind of [INAUDIBLE] coffee,
as well as the tower and so on.
So it seems that the system are
able to recognize environment
of object.
But what they learn are
the part and the object
that the environment contain.
And I'm going to show
example of those.
So jumping, just giving you
a result in neuroscience.
And so there's a lot of debate
out there about, OK, well,
there's those model
with different layers.
And you have different
models out there.
To which extent they correspond
to the visual hierarchy
of the human brain?
Well, first, the
computational model
were inspire by the visual
hierarchy, the V1, V2, V4,
and [INAUDIBLE]
and so on, knowing
that more complex features
are built over time and space.
So what you can also do
is run through a network
and run in an fMRI
experiment the same image,
and then look at the correlation
existing between the responses
of the cells, let's
say in layer one,
and the responses you may
have on the human brain
in different part of the brain.
And what we find is that the
layer one will correspond more,
will have a higher
correlation, with responses
in the visual area,
literally V1, V2.
And as you move up
through the layers,
then there is correlation,
higher [INAUDIBLE] correlation,
with part of the ventral and
the parietal part of the brain.
And I know you had the lecture
by Jim DiCarlo that actually
must have explained this.
So Jim DiCarlo team did it, Jack
Gallant as well in Berkeley.
And we also did
it with other type
of images and other network,
and all the result really
corroborate each other
with this nice correlation
between low to high visual
areas between the brain,
the human brain, and
those multi-layers model.
All right.
Let me show you some
of the receptive
field, the artificial
receptive field
that we find in
the higher layers.
So this network was trained
for scene categorization.
So the only thing
that this network,
the one we are using
here, learn was
to discriminate between, in
this case, 200 categories--
the kitchen, the bedroom,
the bathroom, the alley,
the living room, the
forest, and so on and so on.
200 of those.
So that's the task.
What the network
learn and what we
observe is that object
discriminant and diagnostical
information between
those category
form the emerging representation
that are automatically,
naturally learn by the networks.
So the network has
never learned a wheel,
but the representation
emerge, as you can see here.
So this is one
artificial neurone.
And it is receptive
field and its responses,
the highest response it got
for a collection of images.
And as you can see, those
higher pool5 receptive field
are more independent
to the location.
They are built that way.
But the network never
learn the parts.
This is something
that emerged naturally
by learning different
environment.
The other thing that's very
interesting in this model, when
you can open up and look at
the receptive field using
various method, here is one,
is, well, this model has never
learned the notion
of shape or object.
So it's going to
basically become
sensitive to discriminant
and diagnostic information.
So you have this unit that is
discriminant to the bottom part
of either the legs of
animate, or even you
can see the trees over there.
So this is a unit.
It seems that it was needed in
order to classify environment
to have units that we might
not have a word for it.
But the human
brain might as well
have many of those unit
that do not correspond
to necessarily a word.
So, basically,
with this model you
can have a lot of new object
emerging that you might not
have thought of, but they
become parts of the code
needed in order to identify
an environment or an object.
So we also have another
unit for this bottom parts
of a collection of chairs.
We also have chair,
of course, showing up.
Faces.
The model never learned faces.
Only learn kitchen,
bathroom, street.
We have several unit
emerging for faces.
Why?
Because those are
correlated with a collection
of environment.
Then, entire object
shapes, like bed,
very diagnostic of a
bedroom in this case.
So that will be a unit that
is very, very specific.
That would be really
only for beds, that one.
And then, others
like lamps and so on.
There's thousand
and thousand here.
Another unit never
learned, screen monitors.
And here is specific unit
for that that emerge.
Also, collection
of object or space,
collection of chairs over here.
The network found that this
is a discriminant information
to classify environment, crowds.
It's a very interesting
unit because it's
really independent of the
location, as well as basically
the number of people and if
they are closer or further away.
But it does capture
this notion of crowd.
So the model doesn't
have the word crowd.
So it has never known the crowd.
It's one of the
unit emerging that
now can be used as
an object detector
to enhance the recognition of
what's going on in the scene.
So this is an ice skating
area, and there is a crowd.
And also unit that are
more specific to space
and useful for
navigation, for instance.
We have many of those.
So in that case, just the
fact that there is lamps up
or perspective,
so we have a unit
like this specific to this.
So it's not the only
object as physical object.
There's also a
collection of unit
that are related to spatial
layout and geometry that
are also discriminant
for environment.
And many, many other
that are showing up.
So those object
detector naturally
emerge inside this
kind of network trained
for scene understanding.
So now I only have a couple of
minutes to wrap up, 20 minutes,
so I'm going to just give you
the hint of the next part.
So with the Places challenge
that is starting this week,
certainly in less than a year
the computational vision model
of scene recognition
are going to be very
close to human performances.
And then there's a long way
to go and many more things
to match, like the error.
So know that the
error look alike
or when a category can
have many type of object
or what can happen next.
So you can really expand.
But let's say we
can consider now
that we have a base
of visual recognition
into a model that works pretty
well at the level of human,
or close enough, or
will be close enough.
So, now that we have that,
we can add the memory module.
How to add the
memorability module
is really open in the air.
There's many ways to do.
So we just did it one way, to
have a ground very first model
of visual memorability
at the level of human.
And this is going to be out--
the paper is in revision--
in a few weeks.
And you're going to be able to
download the images, the model,
and so on.
Again, this is model number one,
and we hope that then a better
model can be done.
So we went for the
Occam razor approach.
The most simple one given
the model is we took AlexNet,
we feed AlexNet with
both ImageNet and Places.
Because all the images that
are memorable or unforgettable,
they might have object,
they might have places.
OK, so let's put the two
together so we have more power.
We train the model, so we have
the visual recognition model.
We do know that those
units make sense.
They recognize that
this is a kitchen.
And we do know why,
because we have the parts.
So that's a classical
standard AlexNet.
The output is scene and
object categorization,
so we are still in
categorization land.
And we can remove
the last layer.
And then this is a procedure
that has been well published
in computer vision
and computer science,
this notion of fine tuning
and back propagation.
So you use the
network on learning
that are learn to
recognize places,
and you finely tune
and adopt the feature
so that the task has change.
So the task was recognition.
And now, for the
network, at the end
there is a new task for
that network that has learn
all those object and scene.
And the new task is now to
learn that those element are
of high, medium, or
low memorability,
which is a continuous value.
So by doing this,
we have now a model
where we give it a
new image, and it's
going to output a
score between 0 and 1.
And the human to human I'll
show you is 0.68 correlation.
The human to computer
is 0.65, which mean now
that there is a first
model that can basically
replicate human memorability
of a group nearly at
the level of a human.
And we use the data
set of 60,000 image
to finely tune the
recognition model,
as well as test with images
that this has not shown.
And because we can open up this
new network of memorability
and look also now at the
receptive field of the neuron
that are related to high
or low memorability image--
and we will publish every single
receptive field on the web
as well with this paper--
and thus now we can see
the unit that are related,
this higher level information
of object or space or parts
and so on that is
related with images
that are highly memorable
in green, strong positive,
or highly forgettable.
And we find, again, that
if you have animate object
or kind of object,
roundish object,
and so on, you can go
[INAUDIBLE] those will make
your images more memorable.
And so our last part
is, so now that we
do have this model that
spill out responses
at the level of human and
indicate the parts that
are related to higher memory,
lower memory, at least
as a guideline, then we can
go back to a given image
and emphasize the
part that correspond
to the high memorability
receptive field
and de-emphasize the
part corresponding
to the forgettable part
of the receptive field.
And this give you
images on the right
like that that
have been weighted
by the element
that are memorable
and the element that
are forgettable.
So maybe here it doesn't matter
that the ground is forgettable.
Here, the part I
like to emphasize
are the memorable one.
But, for instance, in this
imagine we have two person.
And, well, she
just happened to be
more forgettable in this case,
which will make a perfect CIA
agent, if we think about it.
And we did tested those.
So then, for a values
part of navigation,
I mean values scene, we do
find that the element of exit
or entrance, so where
there's basically
path and a 3D structure
for navigation,
tend also to be more memorable.
So those are highlighted
in those images.
Another example,
where the kids will
be more memorable than the
features of the person.
And I don't--
Well, I'm not an expert in game.
You can explain that one to me.
So I have to stop
because we need a break,
and I might need to talk.
However, here is a vision
of where we are going.
And maybe other people
will be interested to go
on this adventure.
Because it's really,
really just the beginning.
But if you now can
have a model that
at the level of a group of
human predict which image
are memorable, and
as well, also match
part of the visual region and
even the higher level object
recognition, then you can start
having this similarity going on
in this study between the
human brain and all the part,
from perception to memory
and computational model,
to characterize what the
computation underlying
those particular region.
Because now you have model zero.
I'm not saying that the
model I'm showing to you
is a model that
imitate the brain.
But it's a model
zero, and now it
can be tuned to better
learn the calculation that
are done at different
level along the visual
to the memory hierarchy in order
to characterize visual memory.